Josh here we go again man froze I mean
the first movie obviously massive
worldwide phenomenon you growing up
loved I'm gonna say the genie I loved I
loved Aladdin he loves Aladdin I love
that I've told this story many times
which is why you're referencing anime
but yes I remember sitting in a theater
in 1993 seeing Aladdin and I remember
vividly remember after friend like me I
turned to my mom and I was like can I do
that one day that is the coolest thing
ever and there was just something about
growing up during that that Golden Age
of Disney Animation you know between
Little Mermaid Beauty and the Beast
Aladdin and Lion King that was I think a
really pivotal part of why I chose to do
and I what I did and to get to play a
character like this little guy is a
dream come true because it's really as
wish fulfillment so years removed from
the first movie from the excitement of
life you being that's me that's my voice
how has that evolved for you it must
still be exciting but what does it meet
you now now means walking down the
street opening my mouth and children
giving me strange looks like why why are
you possessed with olaf's of voice yeah
there's a a real sense of gratification
the fact that this character has touched
so many lives has been something that in
my wildest dreams I couldn't have
anticipated or imagined for me the the
real joy of frozen - though is getting
to evolve the character because there
was no reason to do a sequel to the
movie unless there was real growth and
real change in each of these characters
and an olaf is no different and where's
in the first movie there was a sense of
wonderment a sense of naivete a sense of
this childlike sort of like wide-eyed
appreciation of the world despite its
challenges and dangers in this movie
olaf is starting to do something he has
done before which question things and
it's it's part and parcel the growth of
any child right and he's at that age now
where he's starting to sort of say well
why do things have to change why why is
life more complicated than I thought it
was and that's not only reflected in his
incredible arc on this incredible
journey but also in the brilliant music
that I think is as good if not even
better than the original and one of the
things that Bobby and Kristen did so
brilliantly is they gave Olaf a song
that doesn't feel exactly like in summer
but it feels like it's a continuation of
of a learning curve and whereas in
summer was about sort of the fact that
he all off doesn't really understand
that if he goes out in the summer heat
he'll melt now he's starting to
recognize the dangers yeah but he
doesn't quite give in to the temptation
to say oh I I know this is dangerous
and so his song in this movie is called
this'll all makes sense when I'm older
and it's really about the fact that he
sees chaos around him he sees danger he
sees that the world is not the place
that he necessarily thought it was and
he's still trying to be optimistic
despite those challenges but even though
we in that idea of like growing up like
oh that's not a full-on grown up yet no
but you want to keep a bit of that old
life in you right that you want oh yeah
yeah and he's still Olaf and he still he
still wide-eyed but he is like my own
children who are eight and five he's
starting to sort of challenge the status
quo a little yeah and he's curious and
he's definitely he has some challenges
in terms of the fact that things aren't
always what they seem that the ease with
which he's lived his existence comes
with more of a baggage now because he's
seeing that his friends his family
really are dealing with some
unexpected challenges friends always
been such a great tale of siblings being
able to work things out right going
through the toughest situations and
coming back together right when your
little ones are arguing Jeff just go
look at on an Elsa they could do it uh
no I don't reference my movies usually
when trying to separate my children
fighting with each other because they
wouldn't even hear it because they're
screaming so loudly at each other but
you know there's there is nothing
greater to me than sharing this
franchise with my kids I just took them
two nights ago to go see this movie and
to watch these two girls these two
sisters watching a movie that is all
about the nature of siblings the nature
of that that love that two sisters have
for each other and see it reflected in
their own relationship that's probably
the greatest part of this journey for me
is that is to have that proximity to
what that actually feels like in real
life and to have this foundation for the
girls to look back on and to learn from
I think is really special